kennen sie das auch sie haben sich zwei
karten für den absoluten lieblingsfilme
ergattert und freuen sich auf einen
perfekten kinoabend mit ihrer liebsten
aber gerade es ist losgehen soll setzte
sich ausgerechnet ein lulatsch eine
bohnenstange und schillers großer bruder
direkt auf die plätze vor ihrer nase
vorn machen ihren wunderschönen abend zu
zweit zunichte aber das muss nicht sein
denn jetzt gibt es endlich denn kleine
leute verleih ja der kleine leute
verleih ab sofort auch in ihrer stadt
schloss mit frösteln isar sich leihen
sie sich einfach ein paar kleine leute
aus für die 63 vor ihnen und genießen
sie ungestört ihren nächsten kino
konzert oder theaterbesuch garantiert
der kleine leute verleiht bietet kleine
leute für jede gelegenheit in den größen
klein verdammt klein und gibt sich
klitzeklein der kleine leute verleih
eine kleine idee mit großer wirkung und
jetzt ganz neu im programm für
selbstvertrauen
damit sie nicht immer wieder letzte depp
auf ihrer party wirken der hässliche
leute verleiht und sie wirken wie brad
pitt und angelina jolie
also worauf warten sie noch rufen sie
sofort an ihr kleine leute und hässliche
leute verleiht freut sich auf ihren
anruf
[Applaus]